Hello everyone,
this is Isaac
Kertzer of the
Department of Biomedical
Science, Old
Westbury Campus.
And this is the
second of two lectures
on the internal anatomy
of the brainstem.
Here we're going to
be covering the major
tracks that course
through the brainstem,
along with the
cranial nerve nuclei
that are situated
within the brainstem.
There are three session
objectives for this
lecture. First, we
need to understand the
general route of some
of these long tracts,
where they begin and
where they end and what
they pass on through.
Second, we need to
identify from external
landmarks and a
horizontal section the
placement of the tracts
mentioned above, what
they look like from
both vantages. Third,
you need to identify
the position of the
cranial nerve nuclei with
respect to their
general functions we'll
be considering six
major tracts coursing
through the brainstem
the cortical spinal tract
will be originating
in the cerebral cortex
and traveling down to
the spinal cord the
dorsal column medial
lumniscus and spinal
thalamic tract will
be originating in the
periphery of the body
and traveling to the
cerebral cortex to relay
sensory information.
Then we have the
cerebellar penuncles,
three of them,
inferior, middle, and
superior. These are
going to be relaying
information to and
from the cerebellum.
As you surely know, the
right cerebral cortex
is going to be
controlling the left side
of the body, and the
left cerebral cortex will
be controlling the
right side of the body.
And so there needs to
be a decussation of
those fibers at some
point, and that occurs
for the most part at the
bottom of the medulla.
The caudal medulla,
80% or more of the
fibers will decussate,
and that is called the
pyramidal decussation.
10 to 20% of the fibers
stay on the same side
we're going to be
focusing on the 80 to
90 percent and these two
slides or these two
images provide some
information about that
on the right is the
simplest cartoon image
of fiber tracks passing
on down from midbrain
through ponds through
medulla then finally
decussating at the bottom
of medulla on the left
we have some similar
information but in
addition we see at the
midbrain that the
corticospinal tract occupies
the middle one-third
of the cruceribri and
that's traveling as
one parallel highway of
information but when
it reaches the ponds
the highway breaks on
up as each fiber needs
to find its own way
through the traffic jam
of information that is
moving left to right
and right to left from
those pontine nuclei
so those pontine nuclei
will be sending axons
to the contralateral
side and forming the
middle cerebellar
peduncle and there's just
no simple way to go
through that you have to
split up and then
recoalesce and that
recoalescing is at the
end of the pond so at the
top of the medulla
and so we can see that
those fibers now recoalesce
at the top of the
medulla and then travel
down together as the
pyramids finally
decussating at the bottom.
Now let us look at
some actual sections of
the brainstem and see
where the corticospiral
tract would route
its fibers through
it. We will start at
the highest level of
the brainstem the
midbrain we can tell
this is the midbrain
because of those large
stalks that we see on
the anterior side we
also have on the dorsal
side these swellings
which are clearly the
colliculi and we have
anterior to the
colliculi this small pore
which is the cerebral
aqueduct. So these are
all features that are
characteristic of the
midbrain. It should be
noted that the image on
the right is more
rostral than the image on
the left because we
have the presence of the
substantia *****. If we
moved up even further
we would see the red
nuclei. So we are
more caudal than the
red nuclei, but we are
still above the section
that's on the left
where we see this clear
decussation of the
superior peduncles. Now
let's talk about the
corticospinal tract.
This red dot, which is in
the middle one-third
of the cruse cerebri,
that will be originating
from fibers on the
ipsilateral cerebral
cortex and it maintains
this position in the
middle third of the
cruceribri throughout
its coursing of midbrain.
Now we're within the
pons. You can tell
we're within pons
because of that bulbous
interior surface. We
can also see the fourth
ventricle behind the
brainstem and behind
that would be the
cerebellum. So these are
undoubtedly slices
through the pons. The most
rostral section is
on the right the most
caudal on the left
and you can see these
various bundles of dark
material reflecting
the axons the stained
axons and within that
this is most certainly
the corticospiral
tract is a corticospiral
tract coursing on
through again on the
same side again on the
anterior side. There
has not yet been a
decussation, but there
are many of these
different bundles
because those fibers by
necessity have split
up to dive between the
fibers that are going
from right-left and left
-right from the pontine
nuclei ultimately
through coalescing to
be the middle cerebellar
peduncle here there
are three transverse
sections through
the medulla the most
rostral section is on
the right the most caudal
is on the left we
can see the familiar
tube-like structure
we have other familiar
nuclei in front of us
including the inferior
olivary nuclei and
the dorsal column
nuclei. Now where is
the corticospinal tract?
Again on the very
same side that we saw
for the pons and the
midbrain. It is in the
basilar region and on
the same side. Those
fibers have not yet
decussated at the
rostral medulla nor the
middle medulla, we'll
say, but only at the
most caudal portion
of the medulla is
there a decussation. Do
you see how the
fibers, I drew this dot
on the right and now
it's on the left do
you see these fibers
crossing right here that
is the decussation
that is the decussation
from right to left
and we also have
from left to right if
we look at the very
bottom of this image
we can see from the
external view the
obscuring of these columns
because these columns
vanish the columns
reflect fibers moving
in parallel and then
when they all move
from left and right
you no longer have a
column that is obliterated
you still have
fibers but they are
no longer within a
column that's why the
smeared out region
clearly signifies the
pyramidal decussation
onto the dorsal column
medial linuscus as
you can see from the
naming of this pathway
there are two portions
the dorsal columns
which are found
within the spinal cord
and are going to be
relaying information
from the periphery on
on up to the caudal
medulla from the caudal
medulla from the
dorsal column nuclei
those efferents those
axons from the dorsal
column nuclei are called
the medial limniscus.
They'll be called
the medial limniscus
as they travel
throughout the brainstem
until they eventually
terminate in the thalamus.
The decussation for
this pathway is at
the very beginning of
the axons emanating
from the dorsal column
nuclei. And so we can
see a cartoon of that
on the left pointing
out dorsal column
nuclei and then this
crossing on over and
then very sharp bend
extremely sharp bend
and then traveling on up
that extremely sharp
bend which moves the
information over from
left to right or right
to left and also
forward meaning from the
most dorsal portion
to a more interior
position that curve in
the road is called the
internal arcuate.
It is the very same
axons as the medial
lemniscus. It's just a
different name for this
very distinct curve
in the path that
these axons must take.
The last point I
should mention is that
The medial linuscus
is always going
to be medial to the
spinal thalamic.
Those are the fibers
that will be conveying
pain and temperature,
and their decussation
already occurred at
the spinal level.
The dorsal columns
of the dorsal column
medial linuscus is found
in the spinal cord.
They're also called
the posterior columns.
the cuneate and gracile
fasciculi. They will
be terminating at the
caudal medulla. The
blue dot that we have,
the most caudal portion
of the medulla on the
left, is the gracile
fasciculus. We can see
that it is the more
medial of the two so
this is going to be
reflecting the dorsal
column medial to that we
see this white territory
which is a nucleus
that is going to be
the gracile nucleus
these fibers will project
i.e. synapse onto
this nucleus and this
dorsal column nucleus
its axons are going to
decussate and ascend
as the medial lemniscus
at the early stage of
this medial lemniscus
we have a right angle
of fiber crossings
that's called the
internal arcuate you can
really see that sense
of motion that I'm
drawing on here going
from right to left trust
me it's going from
left to right as well
and we have a
rearrangement of the fibers
in space they don't
merely just flip on over
as as they decussate
they move on forward
and have this more um
sagittal orientation
okay and you could look
at this mustache of
a fella that was famous
in his day charlie
chaplin now you could
think well that mustache
that he has kind of
looks like these uh
orientation of these
fibers for the medial
lemniscus. And when
you're moving throughout
the medulla, it will
look like Charlie
Chaplin's mustache from
the mid-medulla and
onward. It's situated
right behind the
corticospinal tract. So
at this point, the medial
lemniscus is going
to be representing
contralateral information
because it originated
from the opposite
side. And the pyramidal
tract will also be
relaying contralateral
information insofar as
it has not decasated to
affect the contralateral
side of the body.
Now we're within the
pons, tracking the
placement of the medial
linuscus throughout
its course going from
caudal to rostral ponds
you can see that is
within the tegmentum
of the ponds it's not
within basilar ponds
which is interior to
it here it's interior
it's a tegmentum
tegmentum and it remains
on this same side
throughout its course.
It's already decasated.
It will not switch
over again. It will
ultimately be destined
to the thalamus on
the same side and from
the thalamus to the
cerebral cortex on the
same side. Now what
do these fibers look
like? We can see that
there's no longer that
sagittal orientation
there's more of a frontal
orientation of the
fibers and you could
say it's a little
bit like this fella's
mustache who was famous
in his day Clark Gable
so you have a more Clark
Gable like mustache
at the palms now in
position of the medial
lemniscus in the
midbrain the fibers have
become oriented in a
pattern that is angular
and outwards so it is
within the tegmentum
it's not basilar
midbrain is dorsal to
that this is all going
to be tegmentum up to
you get to the tectum
or the superior
colliculi so it's in the
tegmentum immediately
adjacent to the
basilar portion of the
midbrain at this lower
level. And we see that
the fibers are oriented
this way, this way.
And you could say,
what about this fella?
He's got a mustache
too. It's kind of wild
and goes backwards.
That's another way of
kind of remembering what
the fibers look like
on the right we're
at a higher level of
the midbrain again
the fibers are at that
orientation um uh
pointing out uh backwards
okay is not this it is
not this curling back
is not this this
curling back we'll
be getting to
that soon enough
Now we turn to the
spinal thalamic tract,
which is an ascending
afferent system that will
be relaying pain and
temperature information
from the body's periphery
to the contralateral
cerebral cortex.
Unlike the medial
lemniscus, it will have
made its decussation
within the spinal cord.
So the dorsal root
ganglion that has an
axon innervating some
tissue, let's just say
a pain receptor in the
big toe, it will be
synapsing. onto a nucleus
within the spinal cord,
the nucleus proprius,
and then from there
that nucleus proprius
will be decussating
across the spinal cord
and its axons are the
spionthalamic tract,
sometimes called the
interolateral tract
within the spinal
cord, but there's other
ascending tracks within
that that terminate within
particular formation
and whatnot but for
our purposes we're
really focused on the
spinothalamic track and
it will be one that will
continue all the way
up to the thalamus
and so I want to mention
this right here it's
a good time when
you see things like
spinothalamic that means
from and to it comes up
again again we saw it
with corticospinal okay
so uh when you see
this uh conjoined um or
compound word that has
two different structures
that you're aware of
i don't know let's
just say rubrospinal
that will come up at
some point that's from
the red nucleus to the
spinal cord so
spinothalamic from the spine
to the thalamus and
this track is much more
simple than all the
other ones we we covered
as far as the
brainstem is conserved
concerned it will just
be maintaining a lateral
position along the
length of the brainstem.
We're back to sections
through the brainstem,
back to the medulla.
We're interested in
how the spinal thalamic
tract is positioned
throughout the medulla.
We can see it is on
the same side throughout
the medulla. It will
be on the same side
throughout the pons and
throughout the midbrain,
and it will ultimately
terminate on the
thalamus. The decussation
has already happened
for this fiber tract
at the level of the
spinal cord. The cell
bodies for this tract
are at the spinal cord.
Now, this makes it a
much simpler system
to understand by being
on the same side.
and it's simpler to
understand because it
retains its position
laterally throughout.
So right here we're
effectively analogous
to the enteral lateral
tract of the spinal
cord even though we
are in the medulla.
At a more rostral
level of the medulla we
can see that the spinal
thalamic tract is
lateral and also positioned
behind the inferior
olive so it's within
the tegmentum of
the medulla. I think
of this position
cheekily to myself but
I relay the joke that
it's sensitive to pain
and temperature so
it's easily scared and
is hiding behind the
olive. It's a little
bit hard to find where
this tract is just
generally. Medial
lemniscus is very clear,
corticospinal tract
is very clear, but the
level of the medulla
it is a bit hard to
find. So I think of
it as hiding behind
the medulla. It senses
pain, so it's going
to be easy to hide.
That's how I do it.
You do it. You do you.
Looking at the medial
lemniscus and spout
thalamic tract positions
throughout the pons,
we can see that the
medial lemniscus
continues to be medial
to the spout thalamic.
that was the case
within the medulla
but here they're
effectively adjacent
to each other
at the caudal
medulla they're quite
separated in their
interior postural
position in the
rostral medulla
when you have the
inferior olive now
that that's gone they
become neighbors
and they'll continue
to be neighbors as
they move through
the midbrain
traveling side by side
now at the level of
the midbrain we can see
the fibers of the
medial lemniscus at this
angler position that i
likened to the mustache
of um salvador um
dolly that uh that
artist from way back
well at the as it makes
this turn inwards that
will be the um spinal
calamity so we can
see little nub of that
um off over here on
the left oh i don't
think that you're
seeing what i'm circling
off over here on the
left we can see that
this is the spinal
thalamic whereas this
would be the medial
lemniscus and it will
continue to have that
position as you're
moving on from the
caudal midbrain to
rostral midbrain. This
is the medial luniscus
and this is the
spinal thalamic tract.
These cartoons bring
out a fact that may have
gotten missed in the
sections that we are
going through and that
is the decussation
for the cortical spinal
tract is more caudal
than the decussation
for the medial linuscus
that is the pyramidal
decussation which is
seen on the ventral
caudal medulla which is
um at the very end of
the medulla no more
medulla past that that
is where you have the
dramatic crossing of
left right right to left
for the corticospial
tract and then the
dorsal column nuclei
which are receiving the
afferent fibers of the
dorsal column which
have their cell body in
the dorsal root ganglion
these nuclei will
decussate for the
internal arcuate and then
medial lemniscus actually
a different name for
the same road that
will be at a higher
level than the paranormal
decussation so you
could have a section
that would affect one
selectively and not the
other in terms of
the crossing over of
information if be very
careful about that in our
description and these
cartoons help bring
out the relative
position of the ascending
tracks in terms of the
position medial laterally
and anterior posteriorly
On the left, we
can see the cartoon
again of the medial,
the meniscus is always
medial to the spinothalamic.
The thickness of
the lines indicates
its closeness to us
in space. So when it's
thin, that means that
we would be seeing those
fibers far away
because they are on the
dorsal side, and they
become thick after they've
done the decussation
because they've moved
towards us moved more
ventrally while the
spinothalamic tract
is pretty much in the
same position throughout
its course on the
right we have the very
same information but
now reversed we're
looking at it a cartoon of
the brainstem from the
dorsal side so that
vertical oval would be
the floor of the fourth
ventricle so we can
see the fibers of the
medial linuscus being
nearby us dorsal right
and then they become
thin after the
decussation because
they're moving away from us
moving ventrally on to
the cerebellar peduncles
remember that we have
three of them superior
middle and inferior
and I will do a little
drawing of each so
here would be the
superior here we have
the inferior and pretty
much all of this is
going to be the middle so
that middle is enormous
and you could call
it the lateral because
it's the most lateral
in extent now we're
going to be looking at
transverse sections
again and trying to
understand where these
tracks are within that
sections and it's it's
it's a bit tough but
you can have some
intuition that the inferior
will be most inferior
and then as we move
through this region
right here associated
with the ponds we're
really going to have
these massive middle
cerebellar peduncles so
the inferior cerebellar
peduncles going to
be collecting fibers
from many different
sources but one of them
you've encountered during
the spinal cord
lecture is the dorsal
cerebellar tract which I
put with a white circle
here and this is its
positioning you might
remember and as the
other fibers coalesce
with the dorsal
cerebellar spinal tract it
will become the inferior
peduncle so it's
just as if like this
would be one road and
then here this is a
larger highway that this
road fed in to at this
point we're pretty
much at the very same
position within the
neural axis that is very
laterally it has moved
from a dorsal position
it has moved more
dorsally than before
you know they call there
is a ventral spinal
cellar tract which is
more ventral than this
that's why it's called
dorsal and ventral
all of that would be
within the lateral
phenunculus but this is
the more dorsal of the
two though it's not on
the dorsal side now
is on the dorsal side
when we're in the upper
medulla it will be
present within the caudal
pons just below the
this large nucleus
here which you might
think is the inferior
olive but you know better
don't you that's the
dentate nucleus it
just looks like the
inferior olive so I'm
drawing the right now
moving the highlighter
over the inferior
cerebellar peduncle we do
not see it at the more
rostral levels because
it has entered into
the cerebellum. It is
still is no longer the
cerebellar peduncle
because it was traveling
to the cerebellum
and above this level it's
within the cerebellum.
It's making its
projections at that
point and so that's why
you no longer see it.
you may remember that
the middle cerebellar
peduncle are the
efferents of the pontine
nuclei so the pontine
nuclei are found within
the pons um within the
tegmentum of the pons
they will be uh sending
their axons um from
right to left and from
left to right and when
they re-coalesce traveling
to the cerebellum
that is the metal
cerebellar peduncle the
middle cerebellar
peduncle over here that
we're not showing
because the image was cut
off but trust me it's
really quite large and
that would be found at
the caudal portion of
the ponds middle and
rostral portion of the
ponds you do not find
it below you do not
find it above because
it is traveling to the
cerebellum and it is
already entered at that
point and the origin is
within the pons that's
why you don't find it
within the medulla.
The last of the
cerebellar peduncles to
discuss is the superior
the one that's going
to be found at the
highest level and And
we have a bit of
the snapshot of the
superior peduncle when
you are within caudal
ponds, but not when
you're in the medulla
at all. okay so there
is no yellow dot seen
for one two three
but when you get to
four we see a yellow
dot and it is awfully
close to the dent to
that inferior peduncle
at this point so but
it would be medial
to the dentate nucleus
while the inferior
peduncle would be
ventral to it immediately
ventral to it now
moving more rostrally
this large stalk like
tracks this is superior
peduncle it's very
distinct at this point
it's it's one of the
most distinct points
that you could have it
in any of the sections
It pretty much has
the same positioning
when you're even higher
within the ponds,
okay?
But at the midbrain,
it's very different.
We can see the centermost
region is superior
peduncle because this
is its decussation.
as the fibers below cross
left right and right
left so it's a it's
it's it's a output
output fibers from the
cerebellum and cerebellum
is responsible for
coordination on the
ipsilateral side so as
these fibers are going
to communicate to the
cerebral cortex there
has to be a crossing
over of information it's
a lot of complexity
and we're not holding
you to that right
really with this lecture
note to say that this
smudged out region those
are the same axons as
we see below it's them
ascending and then
decussating and then
they will ultimately
be targeting structures
that are going to be
um um more rostral like
the red nucleus like
the thalamus and so on
cranial nerves was
a topic that was
covered in your foundation
of medicine lectures
and you learned
the name of the
cranial nerves that are
linked to the brainstem
nerves 3 through
12 and you learned
that some are sensory
and some are motor
and some are both and
here is a reminder
rhyme for that what
you did not cover
were the nuclei that
are associated with
these nerves those
were cranial nerve
lectures and we're
going to be now trying
to relate those
nerves to the nuclei
they're not free
-floating axons the axons
either terminate on
a nucleus or they
arise from a nucleus
in the brainstem and
this is the point
we're going to be
making that transition
but before that I I
want you to re
-familiarize yourself with
the names of the
various nerves and
whether they are
sensory, motor, or both.
Cranial nerve nuclei
have a consistent
rostrocaudal position
according to their associated
nerve and a consistent
medial lateral
position within the
brainstem according to their
function so we can see
the numbering is for
the insertion of the
nerves and then there
is going to be ovals
of various length that
will be indicating the
nucleus placement and
a cartoon of its
extent and you can I'm
trying to convey here
is that the nucleus for
cranial nerve 3 is within
the midbrain so the
cranial nerve 3 pen rate
exits at the midbrain
as nucleus is found
within the midbrain
same with the nucleus
for cranial nerve 4 so
that's the trochleus
nucleus that will be
linked to the trochlear
nerve the nerve of
exits from the midbrain
the nucleus is found
within the midbrain and
that's generally the
case so the nerve
nuclei have a consistent
rostrocaudal position
according to nerve oh
let me give you another
example 12 which is
the hypoglossal nerve
it has a nucleus called
hypoglossal nucleus
and it also will be at
the medulla so that is
um quite helpful another
thing that's helpful
to know is that the
nuclei for which is a
long list about 20 that
will be on the next
slides those can be
broken down to several
different unique general
functions. We can say
that they're motor
and we can say that
they're sensory. None of
these nuclei are
sensory and motor. That
doesn't exist. They are
motor or they are sensory
that's unlike nerves
which can be mixed
now if their motor we
can break down their
function into somatic
motor brachial motor or
visceral motor and that
would be according to
the type of tissue
that they innervate are
they innervating muscles
are they going to
be ultimately driving
glands through activating
a ganglia of the
peripheral nervous system
excuse me then there is
the sensory functions
for which we have
visceral somatic and
special sensory and all
of the these are grouped
together and said
these will be lateral
the sensory the nuclei
having these general
sensory functions while
motor are medial and
you can see this in
the cartoon image that
I have here the
positioning of the cranial
nuclei is at this cartoon
form for this lecture
I'm not going to be
testing on particular
nuclei here that's
covered in lab four which
is likely to be several
weeks away okay so
this is not to overwhelm
you but to try to
provide a foundation for
you to understand the
positioning of these
nuclei and it's not
just *****-nilly so why
do the cranial nerve
nuclei have this medial
lateral relation where
motor's medial sensory
is lateral and the
the answer is because
it developed that way
so it seems complex now
but it wasn't always
that case and then as
it developed it went
from being something
that is simple to
something that is much
less intuitive so let's go
back to that
neuroembryology lecture that
you had and you have
the neural tube which is
kind of like the spinal
cord where the there
is a basal and a LR
plate and the basal
portion is where you
would be having the motor
neurons and the LR
dorsal portion is where
you have the sensory
neurons and it continues
to have this arrangement
when we have a
fully developed spinal
cord we have the the
dorsal horn and the
ventral horn of the spinal
cord but we're talking
about the brainstem
and the brainstem is
going to be controlling
the um the structures
of the head and the
head is um we have the
brain uh the developing
brain within the cranium
and it's very space
limited and you are
growing those neurons
at an extremely
high rate. You're
developing a large
brain. And so in order to
accommodate all the
neural tissue within
this limited space,
you have folds.
And so here you have
the pontine
flexor, which is a
major folding of
the neural material,
which is going
to create the
fourth ventricle
on the dorsal side.
Now what does that
have to do with
the medial lateral
arrangements
of these nuclei?
Let me tell you.
Imagine a hinge
for two doors that
are going to run
to the back. At
the beginning those
two doors are
touching each other.
But with development and
this pontine flexure,
those doors move
away from each other.
Remember there's
a hinge at the
front and the
doors are going
to be swinging
open this way.
And that is what we
have going on here
there's been the swinging
open of those doors
being that the tissue
has rotated from
the dorsal position to
the lateral position
such that now the
sensory neurons are
lateral and the motor
neurons are medial and
because you had the
viscalsensory and
visceromotor adjacent
to each other in
this positioning or at
stage of development
they become mirroring
to each other
at this other stage
so that the visceral
sensory are nearby
the visceral motor
whereas the somatic
sensory and the somatic
motor are more separate
from each other
this chart includes
all the cranial nerve
nuclei as well as all
the cranial nerves
they're associated with
the brainstem okay so
the nerves 3 through
12 form the rows going
from top to bottom and
then we have the nuclei
that are found within
a particular cell
that will be associated
with a nerve and a
function So we have the
six general functions
for those cranial
nerve nuclei. Remember,
they're going to be
sensory or
motor, not both.
So we have ocular motor
nucleus, trochlear,
abducens, and hypoglossal,
all being somatic
motor, and that's
quite different than, I
don't know, let's just
say vestibular and
cochlear which is special
sensory on the far
right and so your job
is to understand what
are the general
functions for all of the
nuclei that are listed
okay you do not need
to know the relationship
with me you eventually
will. But for this
lecture, we are not
holding you to
understanding what's the
relationship between the
nerves and the nuclei,
because that gets quite
complex. So we say
cranial nerve nine is
associated with a whole
pile of nuclei, and
a given nuclei might
be associated with
several cranial nerves.
Working through all of
that, we do not have
enough time for. Okay,
we're building on up.
In building on
up, what your
job is here to understand
there are 20 cranial
nerve nuclei to consider.
And there's going to
be, each one will be
characterized as having
a particular function,
be it somatomotor,
brochiomotor, visceromotor,
and so on and so
that's what you're
going to have to draw
out and try to understand
what their general
general layout is
because the specific
layout will be presented
in lab four which is
about the internal anatomy
of the brain stem for
cranial nerve nuclei
and other structures
And that is tough,
right? That is very
tough to say, oh, that
little bump right there
or that little cluster,
that's this nucleus.
This is more general,
but it is a fair
amount of material to
process. So that's where
we've broken it up.
here is a another slide
presenting similar
information that we
had for the chart but
not in a chart form
it's going to be laying
out the information in
terms of the placement
of these nuclei within
the different rostral
caudal positions of
the brainstem be it
in the midbrain pons
and medulla we're not
going to be really
testing that right now but
something to help
you build up that
understanding you have a
pretty good intuition for
some of these because
we have an ocular
motor nucleus which goes
with the ocular motor
nerve and that we
already talked about that
the nerve the nucleus
is going to be pretty
much at the same
level as the nerve so
you will be able to piece
some of this information
together and then i
have some qualifiers
to the side that say
well there's a little
bit of complexity
there's always there's
there's this complexity
and then there's
further complexity and
i'm going to kind of
push that further
complexity to the side and
only bring it up as
needed and that is
ambiguous as a brachial
component and a visceral
efferent component
which you will learn is
for inhibiting the
heart rate and so we'll
kind of make a special
note about that now
also in some textbooks
spinal accessory is
classifies as brachial
sometimes it's somatic
motor and that's
because it has certain
complexities which we're
not going to really
deal with anymore
suffice to say I felt it
was best to put within
the brachial column.
That's all the
material that we have
for this lecture.
Let's summarize.
The major descending
and ascending
tracts have distinct
trajectories
throughout the brainstem.
The corticospinal tract
is always the most
ventral. It decussates
in the lower medulla.
The DCML decussates in
the upper medulla and
changes position through
the brainstem but
is always more medial
than the spinothalamic
tract the spinothalamic
tract decussates
in the spinal cord is
always lateral to the
DCML the three cerebellar
peduncles are present
at different levels
of the brainstem
inferior for medulla and
lower pons middle for
pons superior for
upper pons and lower
midbrain the cranial nerve
nuclei have a rostral
caudal placement roughly
aligned with cranial
nerves and that
there is a rational
arrangement of the
cranial nerve nuclei where
there are three motor
columns that are medial
and three sensory
columns that are lateral.
I hope that material was
presented clearly enough.
Feedback is welcome.